22 winners all under age 20
$100,000 to drop out of school and
pursue our dreams this is team
Technorati
the Fellowship's at mcmaster first
anchor presented to the world to our
pure community that we came from
trying to find the cumulus altitude hey
Kevin right I'm Kai shek I remember
being part of this summit a year back in
New York and now I am one of the fellows
kind of all circle that it happened for
me wanting to be a fellow and seeing
these people and kind of keeping them as
my role models to being one of them how
was your journey of the fellow like when
you 2013 right yeah Andrew how are you
doing like last time you met it is that
the finalists strong right it is right
now okay all right now you want to go
yeah sure right now we are going to go
into a breakout session where people
talk about life hacking techniques
productivity hacks a bunch of them so I
bet this will be super nice to have it
is something that you do regularly so
there must be something that's like
triggering you to do it like when I get
up I brush my teeth that's the trigger
and there are all the things that affect
whether you have a habit so sometimes
there's a habit you want but there's a
skill that you don't have if that's the
case there's this like strong aversive
fact is like a stopping arrow
I'm akashic nice to meet you 2014 thank
you fellas
so this year in fact I am one of the 20
fellows and the attendees who look up to
me or will ask me how I became a fellow
so that's a responsibility and and one
that I hope I can carry out the best of
infinity it's a low cost robotics
platform just a prototype we have a guy
in China working on
for us you have a prototype at work
we've been working on it for about two
years
so and you're 14 i'm 13:30 nice how old
you think I am hey thought that you were
achieved when you take you talk you know
older than me my favorite young man I'm
going to what 19
I had the benefit of skipping high
school and going straight to uni in fact
if I were miner with an undergraduate
degree it means a lot more than it
should but it does mean something right
so I should probably go back to school
since the fellowship pity that they give
out to all the fellows it says 20 so
we're the 20 under 20 I feel like many
people who are meeting look at the
hoodie and they go like oh you're a
fellow I feel it's kind of like the
identifying mark and it's deafening
sighting to be recognized right now
walking towards the main auditorium and
I feel everyone is inside because the
fellowship talks are happening right now
my fellow contrarians like you I
realized early on that a traditional
path was not the way for me you're the
ones who aren't afraid to be different
you're the ones who are down to pursue
something weird but something important
with single-minded obsession to be bold
and to never settle because the truth is
if we want a better future it's not
going to happen automatically we've got
to make it happen and we got to start
now Thanks
in closing we are going to do a QA
session with our fellows I'm Katherine
ray
I'm Johnson I'm Cossack I'm Alex hi I'm
Lucy and Rebecca Joel I'm Thomas
I left high school after my freshman
year a few years back I was very
fortunate to have met with 2011
generation and I see minors who were
taking a giant risk in their life to
change the world I didn't think that I
would get the fellowship and I really
put the fellows up on this like magical
pedestal and there's something very
important that Danielle said to me and
that she has to remember that Peter teal
puts his pants on every way the guy who
actually convinced me to apply for the
fellowship I was like Alex you hold it
you're gonna get it you got this is your
totally the caliber to apply so I
actually bet him 0.25 percent of my
winnings
$200 that I would not get the fellowship
and then what I did is actually a photo
and you do my words this is my very
first summit it's amazing to meet you
it's amazing to meet the future it's
amazing to see in other people where you
began and what possibilities why ahead
I've been won multiple times
the Silicon Valley echo chamber that you
get stuck here and you feel this is a
world but the ultimate idea is that
you're creating things to help the wider
world in general you are trying to make
things that will help the next billion
people and that's a big dream at the
same time she's been very true to myself
and signing myself over the course of
two years we've made it this far now the
future is ours for the taking
which one of us will find success in
Silicon Valley find out in the next
season of teen technorati
be sure to subscribe to the wired
Channel